In this video, I'll go over the skeleton retargeting.
This way all of our animations are effectively getting retargeted at once.
So I'm here in the engine, I'm going to work my way to complete characters folder.
So I'm looking at my skeletal meshes and the warrior skeleton again.
Now when we retargeted animations, they were automatically duplicated for us.
With skeleton retargeting, it's a good practice to duplicate the skeletal mesh first.
So that way if you goof and you mess up, you've got a backup.
So I'll go to the cardboard skeletal mesh, right click, duplicate, and I'm just going
to give it an underscore RT suffix so that I know this is the one that's been retargeted.
If you are retargeting with multiple characters, maybe you give a little bit more specific suffix
so you know which one goes to which.
But for now, underscore RT for this example is fine.
So I'm going to right click on this newly created skeletal mesh and go up to skeleton
and there's this assign skeleton option.
So I'm going to click on that.
And there's an extra skeleton that came with this pack.
It's called Barbarous.
We haven't done any retargeting on it.
That's why we see all of the angry red letters.
If I were to accidentally click on warrior skeleton, it would not be the end of the world.
Effectively nothing would happen because that's what it's set to right now.
And then UE4 mannequin skeleton, that's the one that we want.
And we can see that all the bones are matching up.
So that's great.
I'll hit accept.
And then okay, it looks like something happened.
We just need to make a save.
So let me control shift S.
And now the asset is saved.
But did anything happen?
I can't really tell yet.
So let me click on the third person character.
And then I have this retargeted card word character selected in the content browser.
And then if I click on this left arrow so that I can use the currently selected asset
instead, I'll hot swap the two.
So I'll just click on the left arrow.
And now we have the cardboard man right here.
So if I hit play, all of the animations that came with Manny are now accessible for the
cardboard.
So here we go.
He's jumping around, running around doing all the same things that Manny was doing.
So I will hit escape.
And let's do this a couple more times.
So let me duplicate the golden character.
I'll do control W, give him a suffix to let me know that it's the retargeted version.
And then right click, skeleton, assign skeleton, grab Manny, hit accept.
And then we'll do that for shell, control W, underscore RT, right click, skeleton, assign
skeleton, grab the mannequin and hit accept.
And I'll say that's good for now.
So control shift S. And so now I could swap the mannequin character for the shell character
now.
So if I hit the left arrow while having the shell character selected and I hit play, okay,
we've got yet another character.
Great.
Escape.
Okay.
And then one more time with the golden character, hit the left arrow and there's our character
number three.
Now let's say I accidentally grabbed the wrong one.
Maybe I didn't grab golden RT, but I grabbed the original one and then I swapped that asset.
Uh oh, the character is in an A pose.
It's just in this default position and it's just sliding around.
Oops, I did something wrong.
And even if I try to switch it back to, oh yeah, let me switch it to the cardboard RT.
Okay.
And then I hit play.
It's still not working.
Now the reason is because the animation class got confused when I grabbed a skeletal mesh
that was not retargeted.
So if that ever happens to you, all you have to do is switch it back to third person anim
BP.
And then if I hit play, okay, we're back in business.
Now this slide, it's just a summary of the different types of retargeting that we've
been doing.
So in the last video, the first thing we did is set up the bone mapping and bone mapping.
That is a mandatory step.
The bone mapping is what translates one skeleton to another.
Next we edited the translation retargeting to ensure the body proportions match the current
skeleton.
And then lastly, we briefly talked about bind poses and that is a step that's helpful if
your characters have different default poses.
Like one is in a pose and the other is in T pose.
After that, you can retarget the animation, the skeleton, or even the animation blueprints,
but that's a topic for another day.
And then one more side note, let's say you are retargeting animations from one source
and then later you want to retarget a different set of animations that require a different
setup.
Any new changes that you make won't affect any previously retargeted animations.
So new changes will only affect the subsequent animations you retarget.
So that's animation retargeting.
In the next video we're going to talk about blend spaces.